[Music]
turned up the final part 27 to 31
there's a leak there's a slight change
in the the four cards from these
sections that were to show that
beginning so I got twenty two three four
five twenty six and he gets the
initiative in the text okay and that's
how the Charter continues with it with
me this side of the card going backwards
so it starts from 26 we're both here he
attacks my knee I parry out of 27 I hand
you a high throw 28 now this hand is a
bit above the head now this this kind of
high thrust down was is really powerful
and if you can kind of drop down really
strongly into it if your hand here when
he heats this year I will get smacked in
the face okay you do that once and he
may be good why didn't anyone say he
brings both hands together the way it
turns over that's 29 and now do it
thrust now some reason these typical
quite low it makes it really difficult
really should be a white truck versus 13
he doesn't cross over right and it's
Frost 31 it's very similar to finish
four five six
well first our thing that was different
as part of our every who's more like
four or five six whisk Isabella nd to
more definite in you
[Music]
okay sus 1qv Joe with sections from 131
like the very basic slowish so whole
thing together another video we learned
something and or two doing the whole
thing okay
[Music]
you